(pounding)
- Ow, ow.
(upbeat dub step)
- I'm going to give you an apple.
Rip it in half with your bare hands.
- I've never tried
ripping an apple in half
with my bare hands.
(laughs)
- I think you're underestimating
how weak I am.
- Yeah.
- You can't.
- No way.
Not here.
- Can't be done.
No.
- Is this what we're doing today?
(laughs) What?
- This is not going to go well.
(bell rings)
- Challenge accepted.
- I'm thinking that I'm
going to try to make
some incisions with this dud right here.
- I think I'm going to
try to use my nails.
- You're not supposed
to use your nails okay?
- You can put your fingers...
- Like at the top?
- Yeah, where the holes are.
- That's not working though.
- So there's a little bit of a hole.
- Oh wow, that's quite the noise.
- Can I just crush it?
I feel like crushing it is easier.
- Oh my God.
Started talking like a lumberjack.
(laughs)
I'm getting one here.
- You got it Sasha?
- No. (laughs)
- I heard a crack.
- I've never heard of this, why?
In what scenario would you need this?
(groans)
(laughs)
- Thighs of steel.
- This is hurting me. (laughs)
- Um yeah, she's like,
Jesus Christ. (laughs)
- Can I step on it?
- Oh my God if you get this.
Oh my God.
- Ha ha!
Hunger was a motivating factor.
- Rip an apple in half
with your bare hands.
- [Instructor] Get your fingers in there
- Okay kinda like what you did.
- [Instructor] Holding it like that
and then we're gonna like
twist and pull.
So let's see if I can do this.
- He's stronger than I am.
- I know. (laughs).
- [Instructor 2] So the easiest
way is to put your finger
in-between, like that, in the middle
and then just stomp it on the...
- I'm not breaking my finger
- Ow!
- for this.
(screams in pain)
- Don't do it!
- Oh my God!
- The first step, remove all stickers.
How'd he grip it? He like...
- He gripped it like this.
- Oh my God, please do that.
Are you still recording?
- Ow!
- Grip at the bottom right?
- I'm about to break some nails.
- I'm doing the palm pry again.
- Oh!
- Oh my God you did it!
Yay!
- Oh my God.
- Yes!
- Okay well
not completely in half but...
(pounding)
(laughs)
- You did it look!
- I did it!
(laughs)
- It's just
disintegrating.
- You can do this!
(grunting and pounding)
- Yes!
- I'm so scared, I don't
want to hurt myself.
- Oh my God!
- I'm going to
be covered in apple juice.
Did you just...
Oh my God.
- Hallelujah.
- She crushed it!
- I feel like its a new party trick.
(whooping in celebration)
- Good God no I will not
take this to parties.
I will never do this again.
- I would need to carry
an apple around (laughs).
- I would like to be
able to do it at parties,
but clearly (laughs).
- Absolutely not.
- No.
If there's alcohol involved, maybe.
But, no.
But you know what?
On a crazy drunken night
if there's an apple nearby
I'm going to tell people.
I can rip that apple
apart with my bare hands.
- I might just prove myself worthy too.
- We're going to eat all of these apples.
- Definitely.
- I guess I can still dip
this part in peanut butter.
I'm going to eat the whole damn thing.
- Sasha, this calls for a toast.
- Don't mind if I do.
- Cheers bitch.